au centre de tous les regards après une
campagne de deux mois à peine 50
millions d'électeurs sont appelés aux
urnes voici la favorite des élections
législatives italiennes non Georgia
Meloni âge 45 ans slogan Dieu patrie
famille tantôt extremiste tantôt
mélony a souvent fait de la politique
aux côtés des nostalgiques du fascisme
italien le modèle de Madame Meloni c'est
Orban qui aujourd'hui considérait comme
une qui n'est plus considérée
aujourd'hui comme une démocratie au
regard du droit est-ce que ce serait une
bonne nouvelle pour vous
ce sera une force souverainiste
supplémentaire qui sera la tête d'un
pays qui pourra peser sur la politique
de l'Union européenne ils ont déjà été
au pouvoir et je le rappelle madame
mélony je l'ai pas entendu sur les ondes
a été ministre de Berlusconi en 2008
déjà dans le siège de ce qui a été
appelé la faire katnas vous avez dit
j'essaie de faire la part des choses une
gifle n'est jamais acceptable avez-vous
dit mais elle n'est pas égale à un homme
qui bat sa femme tous les jours tout le
monde peut faire mieux
moi aussi mais je crois pas que ce soit
ça le problème on a des différences qui
sont importantes là j'ai trouvé sa
réaction choquante je trouvais qu'il
était pas à la hauteur de ce qui se
passe dans la société des violences
subies par les femmes j'ai été choqué
par le fait que un certain nombre
d'autres confrères à vous ne l'est pas
fait et qu'ils aient coupé cette phrase
et qu'ils aient enlevé la partie qui est
importante de cette phrase qui dit
qu'une gifle est toujours inacceptable
et je le redis ici une gifle est une
violence inacceptable c'était il y a un
an depuis un an il n'y a pas de récidive
donc on doit tenir compte du fait que
cet homme s'amende en public qu'il est
dans une procédure de divorce et que
toute la France mêle de son divorce
personne ne sait aujourd'hui ne sait ce
que pense Céline cadenas de ce sujet et
donc je pense qu'on ferait bien mieux
d'arrêter un petit peu de temps
qu'est-ce que vous vous laissez entendre
qu'au fond l'histoire est plus
compliquée je ne veux rien laisser
entendre il ne m'appartient pas et ce
n'est pas à ma responsabilité de parler
à sa place Jordan Bardella justement il
est en campagne à Rennes aujourd'hui et
vous allez voir ces images qui ont été
postées là il y a quelques minutes sur
son réseau social sur son compte Twitter
ce sont des militants en tifac qui
bloquent l'accès à la salle où il doit
intervenir est-ce que vous demandez
aujourd'hui à Julien Bayou de
démissionner de ses fonctions au sein du
parti c'est les antifas qu'il faut
interdire et pas un mouvement politique
qui représente aujourd'hui 89 députés à
l'Assemblée nationale n'inversait pas
les rôles la violence et les du côté de
nos adversaires politiques
à quelques crasseux de gauche qui
manifestent dans les rues ajoutant des
cailloux vous n'êtes pas une victime
vous êtes une femme politique et nous
sommes en boutique et nous sommes en
droit de nous interroger débat c'est un
bon combat et voyez me renvoyer en
permanence à la position de victime
c'est encore une non je dis je viens de
dire mais ça n'est pas possible de poser
le début
je pense qu'il est de bonne intelligence
à la fois qu'il quitte ses fonctions de
co-président du groupe
à l'Assemblée nationale et que on
accélère sa mise en retrait aussi du
secrétariat national d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts je viens de vous dire vous
n'êtes pas je viens de dire vous n'êtes
pas une victime vous n'avez pas entendu
vers une heure du matin heure française
cet astéroïde de 160 mètres de diamètre
soit un peu plus de la moitié de la Tour
Eiffel sera percuté par un engin envoyé
par la NASA cette mission baptisée d'art
est un test grandeur nature c'est une
manœuvre délicate qui est en cours
depuis ce matin à l'aéroport de
Montpellier au lendemain de la sortie de
piste d'un avion de frais qui s'est
retrouvé le nez dans l'eau entraînant la
fermeture de l'aéroport diffusée en
direct par la NASA la mission pourra
être suivie par tous des images inédites
et certainement surprenante très
attendue par les scientifiques on
pourrait croire que c'est de la boxe
mais pas du tout c'est du NASCAR du
sport automobile après un accident sans
gravité un pilote s'évangé sur son rival
il a fallu l'intervention vous le voyez
de plusieurs personnes pour mettre fin à
l'altercation